this is like the first mcu movie i can
think of where i didn't watch the
trailers this went to this movie like i
don't know jack [ __ ] about this let's
just let it happen
kind of felt good
[Music]
the eternals
is it the eternals oh it's eternals or
marvel studios eternals there's no v i'm
just putting these where there shouldn't
be these i'm sorry so eternals is a new
mcu movie when i say i don't know jack
[ __ ] about eternals not just talking
about the movie i don't know about
eternals the comic book either we're
officially in deep cut territory here
iron man thor captain america hawkeye i
knew them eternals
not really but the gist is the eternals
are these demigoddish characters who are
very old who came to earth and had
absolutely no prime directive whatsoever
the federation would not stand for it
but hey different logistics it was a
different time so they came to earth and
because these demigods with super
advanced technology came to earth and
interacted with humans it shaped our
civilizations our culture
our mythology now they've been on earth
since then it's now modern day and a big
bad thing is going to happen to earth
and they have to stop it and i had heard
that this is a different kind of mcu
movie doesn't really feel like an mcu
movie
it does
i mean it does in the movie i was
thinking okay what would this movie feel
like if it wasn't in the mcu and the
answer is very different it's a very mcu
ified movie about
immortals who inspired mythology but
still has that mcu dna is that code for
there's a super cgi beat down in the end
kind yeah
it is it's kind of code for that as for
the cast the cast was fine the cast did
a good job none of the cast
are here to sell tickets but that kind
of makes sense there's a great video of
anthony mackie floating around the
internet where he talks about how people
don't buy tickets to see sylvester
stallone or arnold schwarzenegger
anymore it's not the actor who sells the
ticket anymore it's the characters who
sell the ticket and i think he's 100
right i don't think a lot of audiences
out there are going to be super attached
to the characters in this movie but
still it's an mcu movie and that's what
sells the ticket here but for the most
part gemma chan is the lead in this
movie she's the one that the movie rests
on more than the rest of the team i
thought she did a good job she's
relatable she has heart i mean by
relatable that is important i like the
fact that in the world as it pertains to
the characters in this movie we built
mythology of gods around these
characters but these characters are as
flawed and human as any humans i've
always liked that concept i do enjoy the
fact that the mcu took that on in that
it's a bit bittersweet there's a part of
me that's like yeah i'm glad that the
mcu's telling that story i'm glad that
that story's on screen and it doesn't
suck
you know
not that that was really the same
but you know on the other hand there's
the reality of the situation that does
end up bumming me out where it's like
this movie really couldn't happen a
movie like this with this scope couldn't
happen if it wasn't attached to a
property probably more specifically the
mcu it's an mcu movie does it have the
humor absolutely for the humor you have
a couple characters that really bring it
and bring it well kumail nanjiani and
brian tyree henry i thought they were
great brian tyree henry was more subtle
with this comedy which i like you don't
see a lot of that in the mcu usually mcu
comedy is
comedy i like the fact that he was more
subtle mcu do more of that but kumail
nanjiani i can't say he wasn't the
funniest one in the movie i can't say he
didn't have me laughing he did it's
actually him and his assistant this
butler this guy who follows him around
with a camera i just i don't know i
thought it was hilarious but as all
recent mcu movies try to break free of
their mcu isms try to do something
different it does
until it doesn't that's why i say the
movie had conflicting tone i'm not even
going to be like the movie was too long
though it probably could have been
shorter i'm not going to say the movie
was too boring because actually the
slower moments were the more
high concept moments that i appreciated
they were taking on also i really liked
dune
and that movie was it was way slower so
how am i going to come out of doobie
look it was awesome eternals
and it is all about execution but i did
appreciate those moments where they
tried to
just
put the fighting down put the cgi down
and have a high concept moment at least
a thought exercise because that's how
these eternals would be they're
thousands of years old they wouldn't see
life like oh you know 10 years ago super
long time there's a hypothesis a thought
experiment thrown out in this movie
where keeping it vague i'm gonna keep it
i'm gonna throw you some red herring so
you don't deconstruct the plot based on
what i say or don't say here but it's a
thought exercise i actually threw out to
a friend once he just he was like you're
crazy whatever my friends and i will get
together we'll do thought exercises and
ponder space time life itself and he
threw out the fact that one day we will
have to go to another planet we'll have
to migrate or terraform we will have to
leave earth eventually and what i
proposed was should we do that you know
all right we wrecked earth's resources
we we've drained earth dry now we have
to go somewhere else
but think of this humor this idea our
going to this other planet will change
the evolutionary trajectory of that
other planet whatever
sentient
life form civilization that would evolve
on that planet naturally now never will
because of our presence there an entire
civilization that would have been on
this planet will now never have the
chance to be an entire would-be history
of a planet is completely altered and
will now never happen because of our
presence there on the cosmic scale do we
have the right to make that call you
know do we have the right
to keep a civilization from happening
because of our want to survive and
someone throws out a similar moral
dilemma here basically it's like if a
civilization if a planet doesn't exist
is that every bit as bad as wiping out a
civilization i really liked when the
movie tried to go there it's like the
movie was like huh they're falling
asleep quick i don't know have cgi dog
monster things come on screen and fight
him yeah perfect then i was like oh yeah
mcu movie that's right we're in an mcu
movie not saying mcu is bad it's not bad
i'm just i'm just saying then the end
happened and then
super cgi beat down and that's right mcu
101. it's the formula right there just
same thing that happened with shang chi
chiang chi injected this new energy into
the mcu i was digging it it was awesome
it was practical and then the end
happened i was like that's right cgi
fight the cgi fight's actually different
enough it's more different than shang
chi not like oh good guy bad guy they
fight
but there was the cgi stands out a lot
in this movie i think it's because
eternals for the most part is very
pretty and very practical so when it's
very cgi heavy cgi stands out like a
[ __ ] when it was all going down
at the end i was like is this the most
expensive mcu movie or is this the least
expensive mcu movie what's the budget on
this because the cgi stood out in this
movie more than it did a lot of other
mcu movies or maybe i was just sitting
there going
i feel like dc did this better maybe
that's it olive branch here maybe it
doesn't always feel like an mcu movie
because sometimes feels like a dc movie
i mean you have the superman character
who flies shoots lasers with his eyes
you have the flash character i
definitely was like old biff on a couple
scenes i was like something very
familiar about all this speaking of
familiar and taken from stuff there were
a few scenes in here that
i had seen in other mcu movies not just
oh seen it in another movie before i've
seen this in the mcu before like someone
does the loki trick they do the loki i
was something happens in here where i
was like that's loki's move by the way
i've seen loki do it and you just did it
again it doesn't feel like that oh but
it's all interconnected and it's the
same universe and these are super old
characters and maybe they taught loki
how to do it rest assured they're gonna
say that that's the case they're gonna
say like no loki learned that move from
this character
like that kid in iron man 2 is peter
parker that's called a retcon it's not
just that one scene there were a few
scenes in here i was like i've seen that
in the mcu before just felt very
familiar like i said earlier in this
video it's like the movie feels
different enough it's like someone got
freaked out and had to remind everyone
like oh yeah it's an mcu movie do some
really mcuish things but in the end the
movie was reliably entertaining as
generally speaking the mcu is it has a
good message about humanity having faith
in people what human beings are capable
of and how human beings at their worst
isn't really what humanity has to offer
i appreciate stuff like that the concept
of eternals is a lot more interesting
than the execution of eternals i think
this movie and what i saw could have
been
a masterpiece of sorts especially among
the mcu but the movie seems so afraid to
go its own direction and commit to its
high concept that it kind of dabbles its
toe into a couple times it springs back
to the mcu safe zone on more than a few
occasions and it leaves you going all
right i was still entertained no alcohol
required but this movie could have been
so much more alright so eternals have
you seen it what did you think about it
i know it's a bit early but eventually
the movie will come out and that
question will no longer be too early to
ask whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you